Madison last time I talk to you you are
trying to figure out if she was the one
if your family was going to accept him a
few guys we're gonna move in together
where do things stand right now well I
don't want to give too much away but we
are together and we've been quarantine
together in LA how how has quarantine
been for the relationship it's been
amazing it's the most time I've ever
gotten with him so like I'm loving does
your family have they come around to him
yet you will see I know that last season
there was a pregnancy scare between you
guys can you kind of talk about what
kind of experiences we're gonna see you
to go through this season um well he is
still away the entire season so it's
we're still dealing with long-distance
which is hard but I'm having a pregnancy
scare definitely opened up a lot of
conversations that needed to be had and
so we've been having those as well and
it's been good plans as of now but it's
definitely something we both want Juliet
I believe that you have found new love
yes well I've known Sam for a really
long time I mean for years he's this
biggest guy effort I love being with him
actually we just said we love each other
the other day he is so kind to me he is
so sweet he he's just always there for
me it's a total 180 from what I had so
I'm really happy and I'm and I knew that
I was going to completely move on from
my past one day and be so much happier
with someone else and I'm finally here
and I'm happy that I held on hope
because it finally happened and the
issue is he used to be friends with Alex
so you'll see that play out you're about
to have a baby
you would risk all that for Juliet did
you meet him through Alex I moved on him
before ups and I were like romantic but
yes I guess so
how does Alex feel about you and Sam
together then he's not happy at all how
still he's not happy oh no no it's it's
bad the group calls me Helen of Troy
because I divided the kingdom what'd
they say they had a lot of mutual
friends
they shared a best friend but they would
never call each other up and hang out
alone that was never something that
happened but they had a big group of
guys that would always do stuff together
and that's officially over now it's
divided it's wild because you said that
you're like really happy for Alex right
now and you're like so excited for him
and then the fact it sounds like he's
not happy for you moving on what do you
think that's about
well I think that alex has had a lot
going on and a lot of it happened really
fast and I think that he's having
trouble putting his focus on what under
should go yeah and I think that this was
just something he's I feel like he's
kind of the mind-state I don't know but
maybe that everything's kind of like
changing a lot for him and now his
friend group is officially divided and I
mean I guess you wouldn't want your
friend to date your ex but at the same
time it's like he's he has a child now
he's with somebody else and Sam was
always very kind of him like hey if he
actually say I'm actually asked Alex if
it was okay and Alex kind of just like
brushed him off like he was just very
mean to Sam and Sam's like well if
you're gonna act like that then I don't
care about your opinion sort of thing
and alex is just not very nice in
general so I'm Sam kind of it was just
like all right brother whatever like I'm
gonna go do what it want be happy
without caring what they feel are we
gonna see Sam and your relationship play
out this season
yes you will it started off very slow I
also felt weird about dating Sam because
of our friendship history and other
things but you do see it play out and
I'm happy that we started out as friends
I think that's the best way
relationships start anything looking
ahead in the next few weeks that you
guys are anxious about worried about
excited to see clearly out
I have supposed to go with some
confrontation in the friend group and
I'm really really bad with confrontation
is gonna say like that's a new thing for
you like you seem to get along with
everybody
yeah so to watch that okay I think is
good now yeah a person possibly oh this
season's gonna be really hard for me to
watch I fight with the one person I
never thought I would ever fight and
they show it all and I can't tell you
who it is it's a girl okay are you guys
okay now yeah um Madison I don't know
maybe because she said the same thing so
that's why it's really it's really hard
to fight with someone that I probably
respect the most on the cast yeah so you
guys have worked through the issues now
we have but the damage has been done
so it's like hard to move past ones
damages time but yeah we are okay can I
ask what the fight is about is it about
ish it's about a lot of things a lot and
you'll see at all and then at the
Christmas party I think the Christmas
party for everyone was a really crazy
night okay Garrett you beat well I was
gonna say speaking of that that's
probably like to the question of one
thing that I'm mostly not looking
forward to is the Christmas party so and
I did enough Garrett all night long so
like he's talking about completely
different things
than me like whatever happened with
Garrett I didn't find out until we were
like done that evening because I had so
much going on it was just a lot and say
and it's at Sam's house his parents
house and his house is very large so
it's very easy to keep very far apart
yeah here why was it hard for you that
episode just a lot happened at that
moment in time just from the get-go of
like you know when we were all you know
started everything and me and Kelsey all
that it kind of just all becomes a huge
huge I guess like mess that night and
everything everything kind of catches up
that into that exact night and it just
doesn't go like super smooth so yeah at
all yeah there's a lot that happen it's
not just me and her other things too so
so the gala Halloween Thanksgiving
Christmas I think everything that builds
up just expound on is that the final
episode of this season know you get to
see New Year's Eve you see until like
you pretty much see until we went into
lockdown oh yeah all the way through
like Valentine's Day okay I'm right
around Valentine's Day and then like
three weeks later we were all and like
that's when filming right now obviously
no no I wish there's they're missing a
lot a lot of new things going on but
yeah with that the whole gala you'll see
from the beginning everything was like
good then and then it just progressively
are you yeah yeah for me good for
everyone else
it was hiding you were hiding that's how
bad things got I remember how yeah but
you could do um one of my producers
literally had to come find me in this
cat
because I was hiding in a bathroom just
does anybody leave the show this season
are like storm-off terasort we saw that
with Cara then no and now Herod
I don't think Cara's gone forever though
we did see her come back a little bit
beginning like 3/8 we saw but I'm just
saying I think Karen may be fading one
of the counselors oh here it are you
guys back together absolutely not
[Music]